any fun memories from take me home
tonight that you'd still like that you'd
like to share yes
yeah
um I love that movie I had so much fun
in that movie that movie was just a
constant party I loved
um
they used every single Scarface
impression
they use it's all sprinkled out
throughout the whole movie amazing
um yeah and um
that's seen in the bathroom with Angie
Everhart uh was
with the the future man and the leather
outfit do you know who that is that that
is a is his last name is Frankenstein
that guy was related to doctor
no yeah it was part of his lineage
really
yeah oh my God
that was the most surreal moment of my
life
with her smacking me bruises up and down
my ribs she's riding me and smacking me
and he's off on Frankenstein and his
leather outfit
did you tell her to really hit you or
you're like no I did not tell her to
really hit me but you know what do you
need to argue with her
uh she really beat the out of me
but uh the reactions were wonderful